Fenty Beauty just released their
summertime collection which includes two
shades of new lip tints I think that I'm
most excited to try is the color
changing pH blush AKA matchsticks so the
shade is called strawberry pop and it's
supposed to react with your Skin's
natural chemistry to create the perfect
shade of pink made for your skin tone I
chose to apply it right on top of the
rest of my makeup and Blended everything
out with my usual blush brush
immediately I saw a gorgeous shade of
pink that matched my skin tone perfectly
it also added that really nice glow I
loved it so much that I decided to pop a
bit on top of my eyelids and over my
nose and I of course had to marry
everything together with the paltical
hydrating lip stain in shade Fusia wife
and it worked out perfectly I mean not
to be dramatic but I'm actually obsessed